c'est quand il y en a beaucoup qui l'ont
vu on va rappeler qu'il a vu le que
maxime qu'il l'appelle vas y à qu'a fait
à que maxime maxime tu peux sortir
attendait encore jean et maxime coutu la
vue ouais ouais jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin
j'ai vu ta scène mythique ce que tu peux
tout cas un résumé du film avant la wii
alors et rosés et a perdu la vue mais
pas aveugle de naissance
michael est un court après toutes les
filles 10 films les comment s'appelle ta
fiancée nadia ouais on sait pas
exactement si j'osais voix ou ne voient
pas malgré qu'ils soient aveugles
moi j'ai pris ça comme ça ah oui c'est
merci tu as tellement de coeur que tu
laisses faire la femme tu lui laisses
faire toute l'année mais le fils de doc
si j'osais voix elle allait se faire
j'ai aimé c'est une vision il est bien
quand même j'aime bien ce train trick de
alors c'est surtout que la femme de 2,2
vous aveugle josé a écrit un bouquin à
bouquin ou 100 millions sont figurent
tous les tous les invités de la maison
ils sont en vacances l'été donc tous les
auditions je vous décris toutes les
scènes d'un film sais pas si j'ai du
film c'est qu'est ce qui se passe quand
on écrit un livre les autres ne se
connaissent jamais dedans la plus dure
est question dsk qui est capable de tout
ça tape de faire un petit show
correctives l'effigié de le faire et
vous le faire ça s'appelle chamboule
merci voilà ça s'appelle chamboule tout
parce que cette femme donc gelé par
alexandra lamy a été chamboulé deux fois
la première parce que moi j'ai eu un
accident et que ça l'a bouleversé la vie
et la deuxième parce qu'elle a écrit un
livre pour raconter cette histoire et
qu'en fait elle a décrit tous ses amis
dont elle a changé les noms pour pour
être un peu classe est en fait personne
s'est retrouvée en fait à chaque fois
que quelqu'un s'y retrouve
il est pas content c'est ça parce que
chacun regarde les petites filles et
regarde des petites choses qui font
partie plan at il imaginé par exemple si
vous vous écrivez un bouquin sur vos
années tpm spécial imaginé et vous
changer les prénoms de tout le monde au
changement par exemple
si vous changez les prénoms vous dites
vraiment françois c'était le plus radin
qui va se dire qui est le plus radin bah
moi je fais alors oui parce que c'est la
moins payé ou non non non mais alors non
mais c'est vrai bon peuple et ont donc
dû le faire ça n'allait pas je te file
des idées alors non mais c'est bascule
c'est michaël youn merci pourquoi alors
elle dira ça veut dire pour qui roule à
240 vous allez à 70 pourquoi tu vas 60
sur une voiture qui va 240 et lui répond
tu accélères toi quand tu vas à
l'abattoir ce qui n'a pas du tout envie
de rejoindre tony j'adore cette gare est
à la tâche parce qu'il est en régie qui
me dit est ce qu elle peut arrêter de
parler du film parce qu'elle est en
train de nous [ __ ] dans la merde
giraldi moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un
hymne à la vie à la différence plein de
douceur plein d'ironie plein de sourires
pleins de l'art j'ai adoré tous les
acteurs sont époustouflants dégâts pas
alexandra lamy que je trouve de mieux en
mieux la donne ces chiffres on embrasse
son papa d'ailleurs ah oui c'est vrai
qu'il était venu avec sa soeur et le
réalisateur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
soit la rési appui